Prof: Okay,
so what's coming for the next
exam?
Well we've been looking at
atoms, and at the idea of
orbitals for many-electron
atoms, which we showed last time
is wrong.
So today we want to recover
from the orbital approximation.
Okay?
Then we're going to look at
molecules.
And first we're going to look
at them in a very unconventional
way,
from the point of view of
molecules as plum-puddings,
what's called the "United
Atom" limit,
to apply what we know from
atoms to molecules.
But then we're going to look at
a very, very different way of
looking at it,
to try to understand bonds in
terms of what are called linear
combinations --
that means weighted sums -- of
atomic orbitals to make
molecular orbitals;
but we're going to try
understanding bonds.
And then these terms that don't
mean much to you now but will
mean a lot later on:
"energy-match"
and "overlap."
And then we're going to get to
reality --
all this stuff is theory -- but
we're going to look at something
real: at XH_3 molecules,
with different atoms for X,
at their structure and at their
dynamics,
and how that ties in with our
understanding of bonding.
And then we'll go on to
reactivity, which is of course
the main goal.
We'll talk about HOMOs and
LUMOs, and you'll see what those
are, and how to recognize
functional groups and their
reactivity;
and that's the real prize,
is to be able to --
you've been memorizing
functional groups for this
previous exam,
but what I want you to be able
to do is look at a molecule and
recognize when it has a
functional group,
even if you've never seen it
before,
and how it might react,
what it would react with.
And then we're going to see how
organic chemistry really
developed, the real thing;
how it developed from the time
of Lavoisier.
Okay, so that's what we're
going to.
And here's where we were last
time.
We were wondering,
when it comes to a two-electron
wave function,
might it be possible to write
it as a product of one-electron
wave functions?
Because we know how to write
1-electron wave functions;
we've got that table,
we can write the real thing,
at least for an atom.
So if it were possible to write
the six-variable,
two-electron wave function as a
product of one-electron wave
functions,
that would be a fantastic
simplification,
and all we'd have to do is
square and we'd get the joint
probability;
not really that you care very
much about the joint
probability.
I suspect you haven't stayed up
late nights worrying about joint
probability.
But anyhow, if you want to
handle things with more than one
electron, you have to have a
two-electron wave function.
And if we could do it from
one-electron wave functions,
then we're really in a good
position.
But we ended the first quarter
of the semester on a downer,
the idea that there's no way
electrons can be independent.
They repel one another,
so orbitals are fundamentally
wrong.
Okay?
So forget that.
And here's our paradise;
it's gone.
Okay?
But are there tricks that would
allow us to salvage orbitals,
to use them,
even though we know they're
wrong?
Okay, well the first,
the simple-minded trick,
is Z-effective.
We talked about how you could
scale the one-electron wave
functions, the atomic orbitals,
for nuclear charge;
if you increase the nuclear
charge they contract;
and we saw what different
properties are proportional to.
So if you have other electrons
in the atom,
it could be that they could be
sort of approximated,
as if they were just reducing
the nuclear charge,
right?
There's a certain repulsion,
as well as an attraction taking
place, if there are other
electrons there.
But maybe we can just reduce
the attraction -- right?
-- and things will be sort of
-- at least corrected in the
right direction.
Right?
So pretend that the other
electrons, or some fraction of
them, are concentrated at the
nucleus.
So from the point of view of an
electron you're thinking about,
they just reduce the nuclear
charge;
and that's a problem we know
how to handle,
what happens if you change the
nuclear charge.
Okay?
So might there be an effective
nuclear charge that we could
use?
So we pretend the other
electrons just reduce the
nuclear charge for the electron
we're interested in,
the orbital,
the one-electron wave function
that we want to find.
So we're going to just to try
to find a one-electron wave
function in a many-electron
problem.
Okay?
And this is what we know,
that 1s looks like that
and ρ scales with
Z.
So if I just reduce Z a
little bit, maybe I get
something at least that's
corrected in the right
direction.
Okay now, these guys,
Clemente and Raimondi,
who worked at IBM in the early
days,
when IBM was the only place
that had computers that were as
powerful as your laptop,
or almost as powerful as your
laptop,
they did things like this,
where they did good quality
calculations,
better than this,
and then tried to match the
wave functions they got,
by adjusting Z,
so they looked like the wave
functions that you get with
better approximations.
Right?
So they got a best fit to
better calculation.
So they found that helium --
which has two electrons;
so it has a nuclear charge of
two;
Z=2 -- you get electrons
distributed, more or less right,
if you pretend that the nuclear
charge is 1.69,
instead of 2.
Okay?
So each electron sort of what's
called 'screens' the electron
from the nucleus.
Right?
Okay, now in the case of
carbon, which has Z=6,
you can also use Z_eff,
but it's different depending on
which electron you're talking
about.
Why would that be so?
Why would it be that you'd use
a different screening constant,
or a different effective
Z, if you're talking
about the 1s orbital,
than if you're talking about
the 2s orbital say?
Why would it be different,
how much you want to reduce the
nuclear charge?
Sherwin?
Student:
>.
Prof: Yes,
the electrons that are outside,
you don't care about.
It's the electrons that are
between you and the nucleus that
are screening you from the
nucleus.
Right?
So a 1s is already
really close to the nucleus.
There's very little other
electron density that's inside
it.
Right?
That's why in helium it wasn't
screened very much.
But in the case of carbon,
the 1s electrons,
which are way down near the
nucleus, have an effective
charge that's almost 6;
5.67.
But the 2s have 3.22.
Right?
The 1s electrons are all
down inside and making the
nuclear charge appear small.
Right?
And to a certain extent the
other, the 2p electrons,
are also inside;
to a certain extent,
but not as much inside as the
1s is.
So 3.22.
And the Z_eff for
2p is different than for
2s;
it's 3.14.
What do you notice about those
two numbers?
You might think they'd be more
or less the same;
and they are more or less the
same.
But 2s is slightly less
screened.
It sees more of the nucleus
than the 2p does.
Okay?
So it looks like 2s gets
more down inside than 2p
does.
Does that surprise you?
Russell?
Student:  No,
because the 2p orbital
dumbbell doesn't have anything
at all.
Prof: Yes,
the dumbbell doesn't have
anything at the nucleus.
Right?
It's got a node at the nucleus.
Whereas 2s has that
first little core,
down in -- the stuff that's
inside its first spherical node
is down quite close to the
nucleus.
Now we could look at that.
There's what 2s looks
like, and here's the probability
distribution that we talked
about: r^2 times the
radial function squared.
So this stuff that's in here is
inside.
If we compare it with the
2p orbital,
you see that this part is way
down inside.
It's not being screened by the
2p electrons.
Right?
In fact, we could also look at
the 1s.
This is how the 1s is
distributed.
Right?
So the 1s will screen
this.
And of course it screens this
part of the 2s,
and it screens this of the
2p.
But it's not really trivial to
look at this and figure out
which one would be more
screened,
the 2s or the 2p,
because this part is further in
than this part,
but this part is way down
inside.
So it's a balancing act as to
exactly which one would be
bigger, and they're not very
different.
But as it turned out,
according to Clemente and
Raimondi and their calculations,
the Z_eff that you
should use for 2s is a
little bit bigger than the one
you should use for 2p.
Kevin?
Student:  Why are there
two peaks for 2s instead
of 1?
Prof: Because there's a
radial node;
remember 2-ρ,
the function is 2-ρ.
So here's a_o;
2 a_o,
when the distance is two;
two minus two is zero;
there's a node there.
Okay?
And it's been squared of course.
The wave function changes sign,
but here we square it.
Any other questions about this?
Okay, now let's look at sodium.
So sodium has a nuclear charge
of eleven,
and you won't be surprised to
see that Z_eff_
for the 1s
electrons of sodium is 10.63;
almost 11, they are very little
screened.
2s is 6.57.
2p is 6.8.
But 3s is only 2 and a
half, because it's further out
still.
So there are more electrons
inside, hiding the nucleus.
Everybody got the idea of
what's going on here?
You'll notice one thing sort of
funny here.
Do you notice what?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: John?
Student:  The 2p
is higher than --
Prof: Ah,
it turns around!
This time it's vice-versa.
Right?
So it's a balancing act,
and who knows?
And there's nothing fundamental
about this.
This was just adjusted by
Clemente and Raimondi,
in order to get shapes that
looked pretty much like better
quality shapes.
Okay, so it's a very subtle
thing.
But this is very crude. Right?
Nobody argues that it's the
last word.
So isn't there a better way to
do it?
And there is a better way to do
it, to get back to orbitals,
even for many-electron
problems, and that's called
Self-Consistent Field,
or SCF.
And it's a recipe for
calculating orbitals;
for calculating better orbitals
than you would get with an
effective-Z.
So first you go through all the
electrons in an atom,
or a molecule,
and you find an approximate
form of the orbitals;
for example,
you could use Z_eff,
to get something that's sort of
approximate.
Okay?
So you have approximate wave
functions, square them;
you have approximate
distributions for all the
electrons.
Now with Z_eff_
what we were pretending
was that a certain fraction of
the other electrons are on the
nucleus,
and the rest of them we forget;
that's pretty crude.
Okay?
Now what we're going to do is
pretend we know,
at least approximately,
how the other electrons are
distributed in a cloud;
the other electrons.
We're interested in one
electron, an orbital.
Right?
Now how will knowing how the
other electrons are distributed
help us find the orbital we're
interested in,
the one-electron wave function?
What do you need in order to
solve a quantum mechanical
problem?
You need the mass of the
electron -- that's easy.
What else do you need?
The potential law;
what its energy is,
its potential energy at
different positions.
But if you know where the
nucleus is,
or nuclei, and you know the
cloud of the other electrons,
and assume they're just static
clouds,
then you can -- it's laborious,
you need a computer to do it --
but you can calculate the
potential that the electron
you're interested in would have,
at different positions,
if there were this fixed cloud
of other electrons and the
nuclei.
So you have the potential law,
which means you can find your
one-electron orbital.
Okay?
Does everybody see the strategy
here?
So we're going to do it one
electron at a time.
So we fix all the other
electrons, all but one,
from some crummy estimate,
like Z_eff_ or
something like that,
calculate the potential for the
one electron we're interested
in,
and then we get -- use that
potential to calculate an
orbital for that one electron
that's better than if we had
used Z_eff.
Right?
Because it's not just putting a
certain fraction of the other
electrons at the nucleus,
it's treating them as a cloud.
Okay?
So now we have a much better
guess for that one electron than
we would've had earlier with
Z_eff,
or whatever type of guess.
What do you do next?
Student:  Do it for
every orbital.
Prof: Dana?
Student:  You do it for
every other orbital,
in sequence.
Prof: Ah, one at a time.
You now know how that one is
distributed in the cloud,
much better.
Right?
And you take all the others but
one, fix them in their
approximate clouds.
Now you calculate a potential
for the second electron,
and do that trick.
Okay, so we repeat steps two
and three to improve the orbital
for another electron.
Then what do we do?
Will, what would you do,
at this point?
Student:  See how it
changes shape?
Prof: Well yes,
it'll change shape.
That second electron will have
a better shape now.
So you've got that.
You've got a good shape for the
first electron.
Now you've got an improved
shape for the second electron.
What do you do?
Student:  Start from
step one or the first electron.
Prof: Or you go,
if there's -- what if there are
three electrons?
Student:  Do all three
again.
Prof: No,
you do the third one.
Student:  Oh yes,
definitely.
Prof: Right?
And then the fourth,
fifth, sixth,
until you get through all the
electrons.
And then?
Student:  Start over.
Prof: Start over.
So you improve all the
orbitals, one by one,
and then you cycle back to
improve the first one again;
go through them all.
Then what do you do?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: Start again.
Then what do you do?
This is why it's good to have a
computer, right?
Then what do you do?
When do you stop?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Student:  When they stop
changing.
Prof: They'll stop
changing;
at least -- it'll be like
Erwin meets Goldilocks
where it's out in eighth decimal
place that things are changing.
So then you know you've got it
as close as is reasonable to go.
So you stop.
And what do you call it,
when you get to that situation
when you stop?
The system is self-consistent.
Right?
That's why it's a
self-consistent field.
Okay?
So you quit when the orbital
steps -- shapes stop changing.
So now you have the right wave
functions, the right orbitals.
So now we've got the real thing.
Right, or wrong?
What could be wrong?
We've got it self-consistent.
Where's the weakness in the
assumption on which we've been
doing this?
Kevin?
Student:  Well you're
assuming fixed positions for the
other ones.
Prof: I'm assuming what?
Student:  You're
assuming fixed positions for the
other ones.
Prof: You're assuming
that all those other electrons,
except the one you're working
on, are fixed in clouds.
But they're not fixed. Right?
The electrons can move around.
So depending on where your
electron happens to be,
those other electrons may
change their shape,
at any given instant.
Okay, it's still wrong,
because real electrons are not
fixed in clouds;
they keep out of each other's
way by correlating their motion.
Right?
They don't move independently
so that this one is a cloud and
when this moves around it,
nothing happens.
As this one moves,
when it gets near this place,
this one gets away.
Okay?
So they keep out of other ways
by correlating their motion.
So the true energy must be
lower, more favorable,
than you calculate by
self-consistent field,
because the orbitals are able
to get away from where you think
they should be.
Is everybody clear on why the
limit goes in that direction;
why the true energy is lower?
Because the electrons are
smarter than you are.
They know to get out of each
other's way;
or at least than you pretended.
Okay?
So what do you do?
You hide the residual error so
that people won't embarrass you
by saying, "What the heck
were you thinking?"
Right?
You say that when you go to the
Hartree-Fock limit --
which is a fancy name,
named after two people that
thought of doing this
self-consistent field thing,
or thought of a method for
doing it --
when you get to the
Hartree-Fock limit,
that's a self-consistent field,
but there's going to be an
error because of correlation.
So you give it a fancy name so
people will think,
"ah, what in the heck is
that?";
they must really know a lot.
Right?
>
Prof: So what do you
call the error?
Do you call it error?
No way.
Sophie, do you know what you
call it?
Student:  Correlation
energy.
Prof: Correlation
Right?
There is no such thing as
correlation energy.
That's not a fundamental energy.
It's not like Coulomb's Law or
gravity or something like that.
Right?
It's just the error you make
when you do self-consistent
field, that the true energy is
lower.
Now if you want to measure
correlation energy,
what do you have to know?
Student:  True energy.
Prof: You got to know
the true energy,
so that you know how bad your
estimate is.
Right?
And where do you get the
correct energy,
or the true electron density
that you have an error in?
Student:  Experiment.
Prof: You get it from
experiment.
Or you get it from some
whopping calculation that's not
as simple as SCF,
Okay?
For example,
there's a thing called
"configuration
interaction",
which we won't know anything
about, and don't need to.
Right?
But it's a much more
complicated calculation.
It takes into account the fact
that electrons keep out of each
other's way.
Or there's another one called
"density functional
theory",
which is also approximate.
They're all approximations.
You can't solve the real
equation.
But these are better
approximations than just
self-consistent field.
Okay?
But they're hard to think
about, because they involve so
much manipulation that it's hard
to reason about them.
Self-consistent field is easier
to understand.
Okay?
So if we're really lucky
though, correlation energy might
be negligible;
it might be so small we don't
care about it,
in which case we're golden,
for practical purposes.
We can use orbitals,
self-consistent field orbitals,
treat things as if they were
independent electrons.
Okay?
And then we're in business.
So we should think about the
magnitude of energies and
whether we care about
correlation energy,
this error that is orbital
theory.
What do I mean by saying
orbital theory?
What's an orbital?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: A one-electron
wave function.
But we're trying to understand
many-electron problems.
Can we analyze many-electron
problems as sums of
one-electrons,
as sums of things that come
from orbitals?
Is the whole equal to the sum
of the parts,
the parts being orbitals?
We know that orbitals have to
be fundamentally wrong,
but if the error is -- if the
correlation energy is really
small, we don't care.
So should we care about the
error in orbital theory?
So here is a scale,
a logarithmic scale,
of energy changes that occur
when things happen,
and how big are these energy
changes.
Let's start at the beginning.
So we take a bunch of neutrons
and protons and bring them
together to make a nucleus,
and energy comes out.
Right?
And the amount of energy that
is given off when a C-12 nucleus
is formed is 2*10^9
kilocalories/mol.
How do I know?
Because I look at the mass,
the rest mass of the proton and
the neutron, and I look at the
mass of C-12,
and mass was lost when it came
together.
Right?
And the amount of mass lost,
E=mc^2, is 0.1 atomic mass
units, which is 2*10^9^(
)kilocalories/mol.
So that's a lot of energy.
Okay?
Now so we got C^+6.
Now we're going to put two
electrons on it,
the 1s electrons of
carbon.
Right?
Bingo!
And that gives us 2*10^4
kilocalories/mol,
given off when that happens.
Okay?
Now that is our old,
familiar friend.
What do you notice about the
ratio of these energies?
10^5, right?
So it's 10^5 smaller,
like the ratio of my hair to
the width of the room.
Right?
So much, much smaller energy
involved in putting electrons
into the 1s shell of
carbon, than in putting the
carbon nucleus together.
Okay?
Then we're going to put the
four valence electrons onto
carbon -- right?
-- the 2s and 2p.
And with that we get another
3*10^3.
So it's an order of magnitude
less.
The 1s electrons are
bound much more strongly than
the 2s and 2p;
and you know that,
from this scaling,
Z^2/n^2.
Okay?
Because you could use
Z_eff to guess how the
1s's are affecting the
energies -- the nuclear charge
for the 2s's.
So you could lower the nuclear
charge from six to four,
because there are already two
electrons way down in there;
and then you have that
n^2^( )as well.
So you could scale the energy
and find that it's an order of
magnitude less.
Okay.
So then what are we going to do
next, now that we have atoms?
Going to put them together to
make bonds.
Okay.
So we make four single bonds
from carbon, but they're to
other carbons.
So for this one carbon we
should count only half of each
energy -- right?
-- because of half of it we'll
assign to the other carbon.
So half of four single bonds --
a single bond is order of
magnitude 100 kilocalories/mol.
So that's about 200
kilocalories/mol.
So another order of magnitude
down, the energy in making
bonds.
Okay?
And then we can have non-bonded
contacts.
Now there are different kinds
of non-bonded interactions
between molecules.
But typically,
to be worth talking about,
they're in the range of one to
twenty kilocalories/mol;
so another order of magnitude
down, or more.
Okay, and the weakest of all,
the weakest bond known,
or interaction known,
attractive interaction,
is between two helium atoms.
It turns out that two helium
atoms, although they don't form
a bond, are attractive;
you know, things at long
distance are attractive and then
they become repulsive.
So the minimum energy distance
is fifty-two angstroms -- right?
-- thirty-some times as long as
a normal bond.
And the depth of that well,
how favorable is that energy,
is 2*10^-6 kilocalories/mol;
so that's nothing.
But all these things we're
looking at down below here are
all based on Coulomb's Law.
The first one was not. Right?
The nuclear binding energy is
not Coulomb's Law.
But all these others are
Coulomb's Law.
But they're all 10^5^(,) up to
10^15,^( )times weaker than what
goes on in the nucleus.
And that means if you made any
error,
at all, in the energy of the
nucleus,
it would completely wipe out
anything that had to do with
Coulomb's energy.
Right?
Because it's so much bigger.
So an infinitesimal error in
nuclear energy,
or change in nuclear energy
during a reaction,
would completely wipe out
everything that we're talking
about.
Right?
So this sounds like we would
really worry about it,
except -- so a 0.001% change in
nuclear energy would overwhelm
everything Coulombic.
Right?
But fortunately nuclear energy
doesn't care about chemistry.
If you change from one
arrangement of atoms to another,
the nuclear energy doesn't
change at all.
Right?
So why is that good?
You can just cancel it out.
The starting material and
products of any reaction have
exactly the same nuclear energy.
So if you're not a physicist,
you can just forget nuclear
energy, even though it's so
enormous.
Okay?
Is that clear?
So forget nuclear energy,
we don't have to worry about
it.
All we have to worry about are
these Coulomb things.
Now, so black that out.
Okay.
Now here's how big correlation
energy is.
It depends on what problem
you're dealing with,
how big the molecule is,
what kind of atoms there are in
the molecule.
The error you make in SCF is
different, for different cases.
But for the kind of cases we're
interested in,
normal organic molecules,
it's of the order of 100
kilocalories/mol.
Now that's an error.
Do you care about that error?
The error in nuclear energy,
an error, would have been
enormous and completely wiped
anything out.
Is this enormous?
Do we care about an error of
100 kilocalories/mol?
Do we?
Would you care about an error
of -- Devin, what do you say?
Would you care if you made an
error of 100 kilocalories/mol?
How big is that in the scale of
things we're talking about?
Student:  Doesn't seem
too big.
Prof: Compared to what?
Student:  That's the
question.
>
Prof: Yes.
What are we interested in?
Student:  Bonds.
Prof: Bonds.
How big is it compared to bonds?
Student:  Fifty times as
big.
Prof: It's as big as a
bond.
A bond is 100 kilocalories/mol.
That means that we're -- that's
a disaster -- right?
-- unless what?
The nuclear would've been a
disaster too.
Why isn't it?
Errors in nuclear energy are
not a disaster.
Why?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: Because they don't
change.
The starting material and the
product have the same.
So the same thing would be true
here.
If correlation energy didn't
change,
from one arrangement of atoms
to another arrangement of the
same atoms,
then it would just cancel out
and you wouldn't care.
Everybody got that idea?
Okay, so the correlation energy
is about equal to the magnitude
of a bond.
But how big are
changes in
correlation energy,
when you change the arrangement
of atoms?
Well changes tend to be about
10 to 15% as big as bond energy,
or 10 to 15% as big as
correlation energy.
So correlation energy does
change.
You make different errors for
different arrangements of the
same atoms.
But those errors are about 10
to 15% as big as a bond.
Now do you care about
correlation?
You don't care as much.
So you'll get approximate ideas.
If you don't care within -- if
you're satisfied with getting
about 80% of the right answer,
then you don't care.
Okay?
So that implies that orbital
theory is fine,
as long as what you're
interested in is answering
qualitative, rather than fine
quantitative questions.
Okay?
So if you want to get numbers
really right,
and the magnitude of the number
really makes a difference to
you,
a few percent change,
then you have to do something
better than use orbitals.
Okay?
But if you just want to
understand why bonds work,
then orbitals are fine.
Okay?
Because the changes in
correlation energy aren't that
big.
So, but for these properties,
for non-bonded contacts,
especially for helium-helium,
the correlation is the only
game in town often.
That's what holds helium atoms
together.
Helium atoms are nuclei,
positively charged;
electrons, negatively charged.
So nucleus repels nucleus;
electrons repel electrons;
nucleus attracts electrons;
nucleus attracts electrons.
Right?
At first, at fifty-three
angstroms, or fifty-two
angstroms, far apart,
those essentially cancel.
Right?
But the motion of the electron
around this nucleus correlates
with the motion of the electron
around this nucleus.
They tend to be in-phase with
one another.
So at any given time you have
plus, minus, plus,
minus, and they attract one
another.
So precisely what holds helium
to helium is correlation.
So if what you're interested in
is bonding, then use orbitals,
fine.
But if you're interested in
non-bonded interactions,
then correlation can be a big
problem.
Okay?
But we're talking about bonds
now, not correlation.
Okay, so orbitals can't be true.
That's clear,
because electrons influence one
another, they repel one another.
If you have just one electron,
fine;
more electrons,
orbitals can't be true.
But still we'll use them,
to understand bonding and
structure and energy and
reactivity.
And we know we won't get
precise values,
we'll be off by one to ten
kilocalories/mol,
but we'll get insight that's
very useful.
Okay.
Now what gives atomic orbitals
their shape?
Why does this particular
orbital have a node,
for example?
We know Coulomb's Law tends to
attract the electrons to the
nucleus.
Why does it have a node and
spread out?
Because of kinetic energy --
right?
-- this curvature of wave
functions that's required to
solve Schrödinger.
So it's kinetic energy that
gives them their shape.
Or if you double the nuclear
charge, the thing gets half as
big.
That's Coulomb's Law,
sucking it in.
Right?
So the potential energy scales
the radius through the formula
for ρ;
we've seen that.
But the kinetic energy is what
creates nodes.
So the 2s has that
spherical node.
Or this orbital here has a
conical, two cones,
and a spherical node;
it's the 4d orbital.
So kinetic energy is what
creates the shapes.
The charge just scales things
in and out.
Now if we use orbitals,
how should we calculate the
total electron density?
Well we have two one-electron
wave functions.
We know the density of electron
one, at this position,
by squaring its wave function.
We know the density of electron
two at that position,
by squaring its wave function.
How do we get the total
electron density at that same
position?
How would you get it?
You know how much of electron
one is there,
its probability density.
You know two.
How do you get the total?
ilana?
If you know how much of
electron one is there,
and you know how much of
electron two is there,
how much total electron density
is there?
How would you get it?
Can't hear very well.
Student:  You'd just add
them together.
Prof: Yes,
add them together.
A whole is the sum of its parts.
Okay?
So the total density is the sum
of those two squared wave
functions;
just right.
But notice it's a sum;
it's not a product.
This is not a question of joint
probability.
It's not what's the probability
that electron one and electron
two are there at the same time?
That's not the question.
The question is,
what's the total probability of
finding any electron there?
Okay?
So it's a sum,
it's not a product.
Okay?
Now we had this question you
looked at before:
How lumpy is the nitrogen atom?
This picture is taken from a
recent organic text and they had
a fancy graphic program or an
artist or something that drew
something that looks very
realistic.
Right?
But we can check it because we
know the formulas.
And if we want to get the total
electron density,
we add the electron density of
the electron that's in the
p_x and the one that's in
the p_y and the one
that's in the p_z
orbital.
So we square them,
and we get this,
and we sum it up to get the
total electron density;
and it's some constant times
x^2+y^2+z^2 times
e^-ρ^( );
after we've squared. Right?
And how can you simplify that?
What's x^2+y^2+z^2?
It's r^2.
Okay?
So how does it depend on
θ?
How does it depend on
φ?
Elizabeth?
Student:  It doesn't.
Prof: It doesn't depend.
What does it look like?
Student:  A sphere.
Prof: It's a sphere.
It's a ball.
It doesn't look like this thing.
So it's spherical.
So forget, for all the elegance
of that picture,
forget it;
they're not showing you the
truth.
Okay, or this problem we had
before of looking at the
cross-section of the CN Triple
Bond,
where we sliced it and turned
it and thought it might look
like a cloverleaf,
or maybe some kind of diamond
shape or something.
But in fact it's round.
Why?
Because
(2p_x)^2+(2p_y)^2 depends
on x^2+y^2,^( )which is
r^2, in two dimensions.
Right?
So it's cylindrical,
doesn't depend on the angle
around the bond axis.
Okay, so this is what we've
seen.
We've seen three-dimensional
reality, hydrogen-like atoms.
We talked about hybridization.
We saw that orbitals are
fundamentally wrong but that we
can recover from the orbital
approximation and use it,
if we -- for example,
with self-consistent field;
as long as we're not interested
in getting the very finest
energy but can be satisfied with
approximation.
Now we're going to move on to
something more interesting,
which is molecules.
We're going to look first at
Plum-Pudding molecular orbitals,
and then understanding bonds,
and overlap,
and energy-match.
Now there are lots of different
ways of looking at the electron
distribution.
You know this story,
presumably, about different
blind men doing experiments on
an elephant and getting
completely different ideas.
The same is true of the
electrons in a molecule.
So here's the electron density
in a hydrogen molecule.
It's calculated,
but there are ways to get that
kind of information
experimentally as well.
So, and you know how contours
work;
it's a lot more dense near the
origin, near the nuclei.
So which contour do we want to
look at in order to understand
it?
Well we can choose our contour,
and we get different pictures,
different understanding,
depending on which contour we
choose.
For example,
we could choose,
way down, a very high electron
density.
Right?
And then we see just a set of
two atoms;
it just looks like two atoms.
Right?
We don't see the fact that it's
a molecule.
Where have we done this before?
Student:
>
Prof: Andrew?
Shai?
Pardon me?
Student:  Difference
density.
Prof: Not difference
Student:  Well,
we were subtracting to get the
difference density.
Prof: Yes.
We looked at total electron
density;
it just looked like atoms.
We had to do the difference in
order to see that it was not
just atoms.
It was essentially just atoms.
So if you look at high density,
you see just a set of atoms;
no excitement there.
So that's the molecule as a set
of atoms, just a set of atoms.
Okay?
Or we could take a somewhat
lower electron density contour
and we'd see that the atoms are
a little bit distorted.
Or we could do a difference
map, as Shai says,
in order to see that they're a
little bit distorted,
because bonding distorts the
shape of the atoms a little bit.
But first -- and we'll,
this is what we're going to
look at shortly --
but first I want to get some
insight by looking at the very
lowest electron density.
So that would be molecules
formed from a set of atoms,
rather than as a set of atoms.
Right?
There are little changes
because of the bonds.
But how about if we look way
out there?
Now, if you don't look really
close, it looks spherical,
it looks just like an atom,
or almost like an atom.
And if you went even further
out, it would get spherical,
for all you could tell.
Okay?
So that's the molecule looking
like an atom,
with whatever number of
electrons the molecule has.
So that's the molecule as one
atom.
The only difference is that the
nucleus,
which for an atom would be in
the middle,
has been split,
to give two nuclei,
which of course distorts the
shape of the electrons a little
bit,
if you move -- cut the nucleus
in two and split it out.
So we want to look at a few
molecules,
from this point of view,
as single atoms --
because we know about atoms now
-- but distorted by the fact
that the nuclei has been split
apart.
So this is nuclei embedded in a
cloud of electrons.
Now what gave those electrons
their shape, the shape of the
cloud in which this thing is
embedded;
what gave them their shape?
We just talked about this a
short time ago.
What gives orbitals their shape?
Dana?
Can't hear very well.
Student:  A desire to be
as far apart as possible?
Prof: That's potential
energy, right.
But that's not what gives --
that's not what creates nodes.
That just causes things to
spread out.
What gives them their
characteristic shape of nodes,
planar nodes,
spherical nodes and so on?
Elizabeth?
Student:  Kinetic energy.
Prof: It's the kinetic
energy.
And the same kinetic energy
considerations will apply in a
molecule as in an atom.
It's always curvature of the
wave function divided by the
wave function.
So the electrons are dispersed
by electron repulsion,
and noded, given nodes,
by the kinetic energy;
and the kinetic energy also
causes them to spread out,
as we've seen before.
Okay, but you see then that.
although Thomson was wrong
about the atom,
it wasn't a plum pudding of
nuclei embedded in a cloud of
positive charge.
But a molecule is
a plum pudding!
It's nuclei embedded in cloud
of negative charge,
but that cloud of negative
charge is given its form by
kinetic energy largely;
also potential energy,
as you say.
So it's backwards from what
Thomson thought.
But his idea wasn't a silly
one, it just happened to be
wrong, for atoms.
So here's a piece of plum
pudding;
which you know is like
fruitcake.
So how do the plums distort the
pudding?
Right?
We know what atoms would look
like now.
Right?
But if you split the nucleus
into several nuclei,
and moved them around as the
plums in the pudding,
they'll change the shape of the
electrons.
How?
That's what we want to look at
today.
Okay, so first we're going to
look at methane and ammonia,
and we want to understand them
visually.
Why do the orbitals in these
molecules have the shapes they
do?
Okay, so there are four pairs
of valence electrons -- there
are also two core electrons,
1s electrons on carbon
and on nitrogen.
So we want to compare the
molecular orbitals to the atomic
orbitals of neon,
which has the same number of
electrons;
four electron pairs with
n=2 in the neon atom.
So there are the same number of
electrons as neon.
So they should,
at a big distance,
if you look at very low
contours, it should look like a
Neon atom.
But what does it look like as
you get closer?
Okay, so here's a 1s
orbital of the Neon atom.
Right?
And here's the 1s
orbital of methane;
it's that net that's shown,
the red net.
Everybody see it?
And here's the -- the contour
level that we're drawing is
where the orbital,
you know, which level are we
choosing?
We're choosing 0.001
electrons/cubic angstrom is the
level we've chosen to draw,
of the onion.
Right?
And here it is for nitrogen.
The blue one there is the
lowest molecular orbital.
But they're just little
spheres, right?
They're like the 1s of
neon.
Okay, so the core orbitals are
like the 1s of the carbon
or nitrogen atom.
They're tightly held,
they aren't distorted very much
because the nuclei have split
apart, right?
And they're boring.
So forget them,
we won't talk about them
anymore.
We'll focus on the valence
orbitals where the bonding
action will occur.
Now, there are eight valence
electrons.
That means two to an orbital.
So there'll be four molecular
orbitals that have electrons in
them, in methane.
And they are arranged in energy
this way.
There's a lowest energy,
and then there are three that
have exactly the same energy.
Do you remember what we call
those when several orbitals have
the same energy?
Students:  Degenerate.
Prof: Degenerate. Okay?
So there are three degenerate
molecular orbitals for CH_4 that
have exactly the same energy.
In the case of ammonia it's a
little different.
There's one lowest one,
and then there are three,
but one of them is higher than
the other two;
there are only two degenerate
ones there.
Incidentally,
what does that remind you of,
to have one that's a little bit
lower and then three that are
the same energy?
Have you ever seen that before?
Student:  2p and
--
Prof: Ah!
2s and 2p,
right?
There's one 2s and three
2p's, in an atom.
Right?
Here's a molecule and there's
one that's lower and then three
that are equivalent.
Okay, now there's the lowest
one, and it's a 2s
orbital.
It's the neon's 2s
orbital that's been distorted by
taking four protons out of the
nucleus and pulling them out to
be where the hydrogens are.
Okay?
So you can see how this has
been distorted,
by distorting the electron
cloud into the direction where
the protons have been pulled
out.
Do you see that?
Okay, now you don't see the --
you have to remove the ball
there, that's the carbon or the
nitrogen, to see that little
spherical node.
It's way down near the origin
that made it a 2s
orbital.
Right?
That's the spherical node.
And it doesn't look like a
sphere because of the algorithm
the computer uses to draw this,
connecting dots with straight
lines.
Right?
But it is more or less
spherical;
a little bit distorted by the
fact that you've pulled these
things out.
Okay, now what do these
molecular -- these are molecular
orbitals.
But that, you see,
is a 2p_x orbital,
that's been a little bit
distorted.
Right?
Notice that the difference
between the CH_4 and the NH_3,
there was a proton that went up
in CH_4, which pulled them up.
But if you didn't have that,
it didn't go up as high.
Right?
But then essentially this is
the 2p_x orbital of the
molecule, distorted from the
atom by pulling protons out of
the nucleus.
Okay?
Or that one, what's that one?
It's 2p_y,
but you have to rotate it to
see it.
If we rotate it 90 degrees
here, you can see that it's a
2p_y orbital.
And again, the CH_4 is
distorted at the top because two
protons came out and stretched
it out.
Same thing in nitrogen.
Now we go to the third of these
2p orbitals,
which is different in nitrogen;
for the nitrogen case,
higher in energy.
There they are.
Why is that orbital higher in
energy than the others in
Nitrogen?
Why isn't it so good?
Because you have electrons up
in that red region that don't
have a proton there;
it's not being stabilized.
Here, the electron density that
went up is around a proton.
There the top lobe of the
p orbital doesn't have a
proton stabilizing it.
So it's higher in energy.
And it turns out to be more
reactive.
What do you call it?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: That's the
unshared pair.
The high-energy reactive
electrons are the ones that
don't have a proton stabilizing
them there.
Now there are also vacant
orbitals.
Right?
Remember, you could have any
number of orbitals.
We're looking at the ones that
you can make from the 2s
and 2p.
But we have a number of atomic
orbitals that we can use.
We're looking at the lowest
set, the ones that come just
from 1s orbitals of
Hydrogen,
and 2s and 2p
orbitals of carbon or nitrogen.
But there are eight such
orbitals: four,
2s and three
2p's, on the central
atom;
four on the hydrogen for CH_4.
So there'll be a number of
other combinations you can make
from mixing those,
which won't have electrons to
go in them.
But let's look at them.
So here are the next four
orbitals made from the valence
level orbitals of the atoms
involved.
So what you see on CH_4 that
this is the 3s orbital.
It has a radial node. Right?
Or pardon me,
yes, a radial or a spherical
node here, that surrounds the
sphere.
So it's red sign inside,
blue sign outside.
The same thing is true of the
NH_3, but you have to rotate in
order to see it.
That's the lowest vacant,
the lowest unoccupied
molecular orbital.
And if we rotate it here,
you can see the inner part.
And bear in mind that there are
two spherical nodes.
There's one that's really tiny,
that's inside anything we can
see here.
Okay, then there's this
orbital, which is the
3d_x^2-y^2,
looked at from a funny angle
where it's not very clear what
it is.
But if we rotate all these by
90°, you can see that it's
like that cross,
or whatever you call it,
of the 3d_x^2-y^2.
But why doesn't it look just
like that?
Why are they distorted?
Why does it have this funny
U-shape here.
Instead of this lobe,
this lobe, here and here,
the lobes moved up there.
Why?
Angela?
Pardon me?
Student:  There are
protons.
Prof: That's where the
protons pulled them,
the potential energy.
But the fundamental shape,
before it got distorted by the
potential energy of where the
protons are,
the fundamental shape was from
the kinetic energy.
It was like the
3d_x^2-y^2.
Or how about this one?
There you can see -- but it's
clearer still if we rotate it --
that again it's that X-shaped
thing.
But the ones on top have been
pulled out by the protons.
Or this one.
That's the one that has a
doughnut around the middle.
But the doughnut has been
pulled down by the three
hydrogens that aren't on the z
axis.
Or there it is, rotated.
Okay?
Now I hoped to get -- let's
just start ethane and methanol,
and then we can get to more
interesting things in it next
time.
It has a lot more pairs of
electrons, ethane and methanol.
So we can compare those MOs to
the AOs of Argon,
which has the same number of
electron pairs.
Actually I should quit now and
let you get to your next
appointment.